Problem 17: Michelle read a book
review and predicted that
the number of girls who will
like the book will be more
than twice the number of boys
who will like the book.
So, she predicted that the girls
would be more than twice
-- let me box it out -- more
than twice the number of boys
who will like the book.
Which table shows data that
supports her prediction?
So essentially, we just need
to find one of the tables
where the number of girls who
like the book, that's just
this column right here -- the
number who like the book --
should be more than twice
the number of boys.
Let's see the girls here is
40, the boys here are 35,
there are more girls than boys,
but it's not more than
twice the boys.
The boys are 35.
Twice the boys would be 70, and
girls is definitely not
more than 70, so that's
not our answer.
Let's just go here, well, here
the boys are more than the
girls, which definitely isn't
going to be the case.
We need a situation where the
girls are more than twice the
number of boys.
So that's not our situation,
because the girls are actually
smaller than the boys here.
Here we have 35 boys, if you
multiply that by 2, you would
get 70 boys.
So twice the boys is 70.
And we see that the girls, at
80, are more than twice the
boys at 70.
So that is our choice.
The girls are more than
twice the boys.
And if you look here, the boys
and girls are even, so the
girls are definitely not more
than twice the boys.
So we know definitely,
that B is our answer.
Go to the next page, Problem 18:
Anna has the letter tiles
below in a bag.
It's very interesting, it just
happens to spell out
statistics.
She reached in the bag,
and pulled out an S.
She then put the tile
back in the bag.
OK, so all of them are
still in the bag.
If Anna randomly selects a tile
from the bag, what is the
probability she will
select an S again?
So this is a trick question on
some level, because this first
part, that she reached in the
bag and pulled out an S and
she then put the tile
back in the bag.
That doesn't do anything!
The fact that she pulled out an
S, and then put it back in
the bag, that shouldn't change
what happens afterward.
If she took out the S and kept
the S out, then this would be
a different type of problem.
But since she took out the S
and put it back in, this is
almost useless information.
We still have all of these
letters in the bag.
It says if Anna randomly selects
a tile from the bag,
what is the probability
she'll select an S?
So all we have to say is, all
of these are in the bag, so
what are the possible
outcomes?
So there's 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10 possible outcomes.
10 possible outcomes, so
that's going to be the
denominator for our
probability.
And then, what are the outcomes
that satisfy our
conditions?
Or, what are the outcomes
where she selects an S?
She selects an S, so there's
1 S, 2 S, and 3 S's.
There's 3 out of the 10
situations involve selecting
an S, so the answer is 3/10.
And the reason why I said it's
a trick question, is because
they write statement which
really doesn't change the
problem it all.
She took out an S,
she put it back.
If she said that she took out an
S, and then she did not put
it back in the bag, then you
would say, oh gee, then
there's only 9 tiles left; and
only two of them are S's, and
then you would have said 2/9.
But since she did put the S back
in the bag, we could say,
oh, there's 10 letters in the
bag, 3 of them are S's, so the
answer is 3/10.
Problem 19: The scatterplot
below shows the ages of some
children and the distance
each lives from school.
So this is the ages, and
then this is the
distance in that axis.
Which statement best describes
the relation between age and
distance from the school?
Just looking at this, I really
don't see any relation, it
seems to be fairly random.
Let's see what the statements
tell us.
As age and increases, the
distance from school increases.
No, not really, I mean,
that would look
something like this.
So this is our age axis, this
is our distance axis, what A
is describing is as age
increases, the distance from
school increases.
The data points should look
something like this.
They should generally increase
-- distance should generally
increase as age increases.
That's not what we see here,
I mean this really
kind of seems arbitrary.
It's not like this nice
upward trend.
B, as age increases the
distance from school decreases.
Well I don't even see a downward
trend either, what B
is describing, the data
would look like this.
Where we have this
downward trend.
I don't see that here, either.
C, as age increases,
the distance from
school remains constant.
What C is describing
would have data
that looks like this.
That regardless of age, the
distance from school
is about the same.
I don't really see
that either.
There's still a huge spread
of distances.
And then D, there is no
relationship between the age
and distance from school.
I'll go with that one because,
you could imagine, if I tried
to draw trend line, I could
draw something like that,
maybe that makes it look
like there's a trend.
But I just as easily could
have drawn that.
And looks just is good to me.
Or I just as easily could
have drawn that.
None of these look like it
fits the data any better.
So, at least the answer that I
feel comfortable with is D.